we are going to begin in ukraine with
the continuing tough story out of there
the ukrainian government warning
civilians in the eastern part of the
country to get out now residents near
the front lines in the east being told
to evacuate immediately as new pictures
come in and we learn more about the
effects of russian shelling in other
areas of the country today ukraine is
again calling on nato to send more
weapons to help fight the russians
deborah patta is in key for us again
this morning deborah good morning to you
every day seems to be worse over there
good morning well it's also not that
easy for residents to get out of the
donbass region given the intense
fighting there the red cross has been
unable to get into places like mario
paul and residents who do manage to
escape have to meet them outside the
city
imagine the relief fleeing mario pole
residents risked the harrowing journey
to berdiansk over 50 miles away where
the red cross was waiting
in another town 84 year old tamara
tralheeb was rescued from the rubble
i went through the war when i was a
child she said now i just want to die in
peace
even before the invasion ukraine had
been fighting russian-backed separatists
in donbass for eight years
senior lieutenant starsky that's his
military call sign was there and learned
how to fight against russians skills he
put to good use when 35 russian
helicopters began attacking hostile
airport near kiev on the first day of
their invasion i was running
between this and that entrance
firing at those helicopters at first i
thought that it was a stupid idea
because they were armored
starsky and his unit mounted a fierce
resistance over three days then an
improbable victory the ukrainians rested
back full control of the airport later
we realized that actually what we have
done here
actually changed the
course of of the war
this is what's left of hostile without
it the russians could not set up an
airbridge to bring in crucial supplies
equipment and manpower it slowed them
down but did not stop them executing
hundreds of civilians in nearby butcher
starsky is worried the war could get
even dirtier he told us they know
russian officers have received antidotes
to protect against their own chemical
weapons in donbass we have information
that chemical weapons will be used on
the front lines
but he's standing firm
named the dream the biggest plane in the
world may have been destroyed here but
he says they can't kill ukraine's dream
for
freedom now senior lieutenant starsky
told us that their information is that
any chemical attack would be launched
against troops on the front line but he
says they still cannot guarantee the
safety of civilians nate
here hearing someone say they just want
to die in peace it's heartbreaking
because they should be able to live in
peace deborah patton thank you